Angella Muslim sentiment is high on the
political agenda these days there have
been hasty arrests presidential
candidates saying they wouldn't support
Muslims in office and the failure to
call out brazenly bigoted remarks we
problem in this country
it's called Muslims we know our current
president is one RINO he's not even an
American we need this man you could say
it's been a bad month for Muslims but in
New York City Muslims have something to
celebrate
literally for the first time ever New
York City public schools the largest
public school system in the country will
officially recognize the Muslim holiday
of Eid and give the students the day off
on Thursday the holiday happens twice a
year this means 1.1 million students
will have the day off
just like for Rosh Hashanah and
Christmas Mayor Bill DeBlasio who had
run for office on the promise of a more
inclusive City made the announcement
back in March it was something that
activists like Linda Sarsour had been
petitioning for for years I think there
is a big responsibility on particularly
the public school system to make sure
that they are educating all students
about all religions
I think racism it's part of a very young
age and if you start Radek ating that
now we may not have these problems 50
years from now estimated that about 10%
of NYC's public school children are
Muslim New York City joins other school
districts like Cambridge Massachusetts
and Burlington Vermont which also have
added Muslim holidays to their calendars
subsume says this recognition is a big
victory for Muslims in post 9/11 New
York the cities hundreds of thousands of
Muslims are finally being heard she says
but while some sort applauds the mayor
for this move she says there's still
work to be done in the five boroughs a
series of Associated Press reports in
2011 and 2012 revealed that the NYPD
systematically surveilled Muslim
neighborhoods businesses and mosques
then Mayor Michael Bloomberg defended
the program saying it was legal and
keeping the city safe but the program
established after the 9/11 attacks
were led to a single investigation
though mayor de Blasio shut down that
program last year many claimed the
police are continuing to profile Muslims
he hasn't really delivered on his
promises of real comprehensive reform
and rebuilding that truck between visa
law enforcement so will public schools
recognizing that eight holiday make a
difference in public perception and what
will it take for Muslims to be
recognized as equals in the US